former FBI director James Comey
highly-charged new memoir slams the
trump presidency as a forest fire that
can't be contained Comey writes in a
higher loyalty that President Trump
quote threatens much of what is good in
this nation he calls the president
unethical and untethered to the truth
and describes his leadership as quote
ego driven and about personal loyalty
the book comes out less than a year
after the president fired Comey mr.
Trump later said he had the Russia
investigation on his mind at the time
major Garrett is at the White House with
details of commis claims major good
morning good morning commis book is an
insider's account of the president's
temper and temperament and the point of
view is distinctly hostile but one that
Comey insists is rooted in the truth
just one example of that hostility Comey
compares the 45th President of the
United States to mob bosses he used to
prosecute James Comey 'he's disdained
for the president jumps off the pages of
his new memoir he describes mr. Trump as
a liar and a bully and compares his
inner circle to the Mafia quote lying
about all things large and small and
service to some code of loyalty that put
the organization above morality and
above the truth I think it's very sad
what they've done with this fake dossier
it was made up Comey also describes the
president's fixation with the now
infamous election dossier which includes
unverified allegations of mr. Trump's
involvement with Russian prostitutes
allegation the president denies
unprompted he brought up what he called
the golden showers thing Comey writes
adding that the president asked him to
investigate the salacious charges in the
document because quote it bothered him
if there was even a 1% chance his wife
Melania thought it was true good morning
Comey also defends his role in the
election the FBI is completing its
investigation and referring the matter
to the Department of Justice for a
prosecutor decision after originally
clearing Hillary Clinton and the email
investigation Comey implies politics may
have played a role in his decision to
reopen the probe 11 days before the
election because I was making decisions
in an environment where Hillary Clinton
was sure to be the next president
my concern about making her an
illegitimate president by concealing the
restarted investigation bore greater
weight he writes the former FBI director
is not without his own critics he has
come under fire from both parties for
being too political and the FBI had to
amend inaccurate portions of his
testimony last May in advance of the
books release Republican allies of the
President are firing back calling Comey
a liar and a leaker I was appalled by
what director Comey did promoting attack
ads on the website lion Comey calm in
another development President Trump has
agreed with a recommendation to pardons
scooter libby for lying to the FBI in
the Valerie Plame scandal that rocked
the second at Bush administration during
the Iraq war
it may seem unrelated but it's not
because mr. Trump's advisors have long
argued Comey engaged in misconduct
during the Libby prosecution and a
pardon for Libby John may emerge as part
of a White House narrative to undercut
commis credibility major thanks